في مسعد لتجنب خرق سقف الدين العامل بالغي
واحدا و30 تريليونا و 400 مليار دولار
بدات الخزانه الامريكيه اجراءات استثنائيه
لمنع الحكومه من التخلف عن الالتزاماتها
في رساله لمجلس النواب قالت وزيره الخزانه
ان امام المشرعين ما يكفي من الوقت للتوصل
لاتفاق بشان سقف الدين ومع حصول جمهوريين
على اغلبيه مجلس النواب وفي ظل وجود تيار
اقتصادي بين الصفوف هؤلاء يرى مراقبون ان
الاداره مقبله على ايام صعبه من المفاوضات
مع اعضاء المجلس
لكن البيت الابيض قلع عقب رساله الوزيره
انه سيرفض التفاوض مع الكونجرس وسيطلب من
المشرعين رفع سقف المديونيه حفاظا على
حاله الاقتصاد الامريكي الذي بدا في
التعافي من التضخم ومن تداعيات ازمه
كورونا في البلاد مدينه تطوان
فان لم تفعل هذه المره فان ذلك يعني ان
الجهات التي اقردت الولايات المتحده
اموالا لن تتمكن من استردادها
في واشنطن الان تساؤلات كثيره حول موقف
الجل الجديد من المشرعين الجمهوريين الذين
يصفون بالمحافظين اليمنيين المتشددين
والذين يعتبرون سقف الانفاق الحالي خطرا
على النمو الاقتصادي وطالما هددوا بالتشدد
في مواقفهم التفاوضها مستقبلا
وان
مجلس جميعنا الرئيس والاغلبيه الجمهوريه
في مجلس النواب والاكثريه الديمقراطيه في
مجلس الشيوخ الطريقه التي ارتضاها اباءنا
المؤسسون
الى تسويه معقوله
رفعوا سقف الدين العام ممارسه قديمه
بالولايات المتحده تمرص عليها المشروعون
ومختلف الرؤساء بالبيت الابيض وانتهت
المفاوضات بين الجمهورينا والديمقراطين
دائما بحلول وسط منذ 60 نيه القرن الماضي
بهدف الحفاظ على صحه الاقتصاد
رفعوا سقف الديون قضيه تمس بشكل مباشر
سمعه الولايات المتحده الاقتصاديه ولكنها
قضيه سياسيه ايضا كثيرنا يرون ان
الجمهوريين سيوظفونها سياسيا وسيستغلونها
في الانتخابات المقبله مثلا لاستثمار في
غضب الامريكيين من غلاء الاسعار وارتفاع
الاسعار الفائده على القروض التي تمسوا
جيوب المواطنين بشكل مباشر